soizic henriot bonjour merci d'être avec
nous en direct alors concrètement que ce
qu'est ce que vous demande un christophe
castaner mais bonjour donc cette fois ci
monsieur le ministre souhaite mettre à
contribution pour réaliser des tests de
kobe de 19 il s'est soudainement souvenu
qu'il disposait que la france disposait
de laboratoire de police scientifique et
de policiers scientifiques
il m'a pas on n'a pas tellement compris
l'annnonce de monsieur castaner parce
que c'est sûr que pendant des mois nous
avons fait grève pour réclamer un statut
des 100 conformes à nos missions qu'on a
été méprisée et qui nous a absolument
les ignorer il n'a jamais reçu
et là soudainement il se rappelle qu'il
ya des laboratoire de police
scientifique qui fonda biologie
moléculaire
entre autres on a plein d'autres
disciplines également et qu'il a des
policiers scientifiques à disposition
lesquels pourraient être mis à
contribution pour faire des tests copie
de 19 donc nous on a découvert ça dans
la presse
donc c'était déjà assez assez gênant
pour la plupart de mes collègues pour
les agents on n'a pas tellement apprécié
il semblerait qu'il y ait eu des
discussions avec la direction des
laboratoires des laboratoires de police
pour pour voir dans quelle mesure cette
pourrait être mis à contribution
donc nous il ya aucune difficulté pour
nous a aidés évidemment c'est notre
mission de service public qu'on essaie
de remplir au mieux tous les jours
lorsqu'on on identifie des auteurs mais
techniquement c'est assez compliqué à
mettre en oeuvre
si on dispose d'un certain nombre de
matériels qui peuvent être utilisés pour
ce type d'intervention c'est à dire
détecter et analyser des tests de kobe
19 ou ne disposent pas forcément du
savoir faire et ça crée tout à
l'ensemble de complications pour notre
mission première qui est
l'identification des auteurs sur les
crimes et les délits
rappelons le quand même l'australie si
vous parlez de matériel quels sont les
moyens vont
vous disposez pour effectuer cette
mission actuellement alors concrètement
en biologie en laboratoire ont fait des
tests de pcr polymérase une réaction qui
sont des tests d' analyse de l'adn nous
au travail en laboratoire de police
scientifique sur l'adn humain on fait
des tests donc de pcr de quantification
et d'amplification pour faire les tests
comme guides locaux vides c'est un virus
à arn pour faire les tests coco vite si
je ne m'abuse il faut faire des pcr de
quantification mais sûr de la rl donc on
ne dispose pas des produits ne dispose
pas des kits adéquat on nous on dispose
du matériel qu'il faudrait régler et
qu'il faut adapter pour faire ce type d'
analyse on n'a pas les réactifs
on n'a pas les les savoir-faire et xsara
faut lui mettre au point donc ça se fait
pas en claquant des doigts comme comme
monsieur le ministre l'a annoncé dans la
presse cette semaine
en fait on transforme pas un restaurant
chinois en boulangerie si l'on me laisse
un peu à peu près ça il ya bien un four
dans chacun des deux instituts mais mais
un restaurant chinois devient employée
de boulangerie juste en plaquant des
doigts de cette façon là alors on le
sait depuis depuis déjà quelques temps
une partie de la police technique et
scientifique étaient au coeur de laver
de la mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites aujourd'hui on l'entend bien
vos critiques s'adressent à christophe
castaner le ministre de l'intérieur mais
en général quels sont vos rapports avec
le gouvernement depuis le début de cette
crise sanitaire
alors depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire
le gouvernement nous a très peu reçu
très fin très peu écoutés on a dispose
pas plus que les autres de matériel de
protection on a nous aussi été mis à
contribution pour rendre nos équipements
de protection pour protéger les agents
que ce soit des masques ou des
combinaisons des surchaussures des
charlottes les blues jetables on a
on a aussi participé à l'effort on a
donné la donné nos stocks une partie de
nos stops une grande partie nos stocks
d'ailleurs vers l'est vers les
personnels soignants à la grèce où les
arbres distribués
chacun fait des efforts qui peut à son
niveau et c'est tout à fait normal après
pour faire des tests
koffi 19 dans les laboratoire de police
scientifique ça sous-entend beaucoup de
choses cela sous-entend qu'il va falloir
qu'il faudrait qu'il faudrait des
équipements de protection pour les
agents qu'il faudrait réadapter les
machines qu'il faudrait former les
agents et valider les méthodes
donc c est aussi et ça sous-entend qu'on
arrêterait notre activité principale qui
est la mission notre mission première
identifier les auteurs puisque si on
fait rentrer de l'adn humain
or or celui de nos affaires on risque de
contaminer des procédés celles qui
appartiennent à des procédures
judiciaires dont on fragilise la
procédure judiciaire un peu plus les
traiter donc c'est un ensemble de choses
qu'il faut qu'il faut avoir c'est une
vision globale qui manque peut-être
aujourd'hui à notre gouvernement sans
doute d'ailleurs en parlant de vision
globale je ne comprends pas pourquoi les
laboratoires des services vétérinaires
ne sont pas plus mis à contribution
eux ils traitent de la pcr
quantification ils sont jeunes mais à
museler la crise de la grippe aviaire
qui était un virus de la même famille
que le coronavirus celui qu'on a
aujourd'hui
et ils ont des appareils pour faire de
la pcr sur de la rn je ne connais pas
très bien leur fonctionnement au
laboratoire vétérinaire mais je ne
comprends pas pourquoi monsieur le
ministre parle des laboratoire de police
scientifique et non pas des laboratoires
vétérinaires ça serait plus plus
atteints a procédé à cette mission en
tout cas merci bouclé à bien et une
dernière chose que ce qui a été décidé
finalement pour les laboratoire de
police scientifique c'est de prêter du
matériel
donc on va prêter des appareils de
quantification pis au centre hospitalier
qui seront réadaptées pour faire l'état
au collégial priori très bien merci
beaucoup soizic envier aux d'avoir
répondu à une question